Christopher Mintz-Plasse first
gained fame by cracking audiences
up as McLovin in 2007's Superbad. He's
continued working steadily since then, but a
lot of fans haven't seen him on screen very much
lately. Keep watching to discover why that is.
Ever since he obtained the world's fakest
fake ID and charmed a couple of bored police
officers in Superbad, Mintz-Plasse
has forever been known as McLovin.
Even though he's gone on to star in other notable
movies like Role Models, Kick-Ass, and Neighbors,
his first role is still undoubtedly his most
well known. That's a fine state of affairs
for actors who are satisfied with being cult
figures forever, but it's not so great if you
want to have a robust and steady mainstream
career. Unfortunately for Mintz-Plasse then,
it's hard for audiences and studio executives
to see him as anything other than McLovin.
It's no exaggeration to say that Superbad has
overshadowed every single thing Mintz-Plasse has
done since . It's a fair bet that at least half
his fans don't even recognize him by his real
name. And while the cachet of that performance
continues to draw crowds for his other projects,
it isn't helping him branch out or
move forward into more serious roles.
"I am McLovin!"
Between maturing into adulthood and losing his
baby chipmunk cheeks, Mintz-Plasse has followed
in the footsteps of so many teen movie nerd actors
before him by becoming a conventionally attractive
man. And yet nobody seems to realize it, including
Hollywood, and perhaps even Mintz-Plasse himself.
So for whoever needs to hear it, here's the
truth: Christopher Mintz-Plasse is a handsome man!
With his comedy skills and very pleasant face,
he could easily hold his own as an everyman
romantic lead, or he could just as easily play
the part of the likable best friend. But instead,
his potential as a perfectly respectable leading
man is hidden under a steady stream of typecasting
and voice-over roles. All he needs is a big,
juicy part that declares his newfound image
to the world, but it just hasn't arrived yet. To
sum it up, Mintz-Plasse is probably dealing with
the double-edged sword that belongs to former
child stars who played one major role early in
their careers. It's as if he needs to look like
his 17-year-old self in order to be recognizable
and land roles, but he's aged out of those roles
that his original reputation would help him land.
In May 2012, Mintz-Plasse scored potentially his
biggest post-Superbad role yet when CBS announced
that it had ordered a sitcom called Friend Me. He
was set to star in it alongside Nicholas Braun as
two guys who leave their Indiana hometown
in favor of Los Angeles and jobs at Groupon.
Mintz-Plasse played the nerdy one who's
content to hang out at home talking to
his old friends online. The show seemed poised
to be the perfect transitional vehicle for him,
as a major network series could've been a
springboard to all kinds of big-deal roles.
But tragically, Friend Me creator Alan
Kirschenbaum killed himself before the
show premiered. CBS decided to leave the show out
of its lineup and never aired a single one of the
eight episodes that had already been produced.
Obviously, a blow to one's to career plans
pales in comparison to death, but this was
nevertheless a tough break for Mintz-Plasse.
Mintz-Plasse's Superbad castmates have
largely gone on to have high-profile careers.
Michael Cera has starred in cult hits like Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World and Juno, while Jonah Hill
has transitioned between traditional comedies and
awards-baiting films like The Wolf of Wall Street.
Some of them have even won Oscars, as Emma
Stone took home the gold for La La Land.
In comparison, Mintz-Plasse's public
profile is nowhere near as high.
Being in big movies means playing the Hollywood
glad-handing game, but Mintz-Plasse just doesn't
seem to be too interested in all that. Sure, he'll
occasionally pose with friends and co-stars on the
red carpet before a movie premiere, but other than
that, his media presence is notably low-key. His
Instagram followers are far more likely to see him
cuddling with dogs or goofing off in his kitchen
than hanging out at an exclusive nightclub. His
personal life is just that: personal. He also
doesn't get much attention for his love life, thus
avoiding any tumultuous, tabloid-ready affairs.
In short, he's just not chasing the kind of fame
that might make him more of a household name.
After the cancellation of Friend Me, Mintz-Plasse
got another chance to star on another CBS sitcom
about people in their twenties working for an
internet company. Entitled The Great Indoors,
it also starred Joel McHale and Stephen Fry as
the editor and publisher of an outdoors magazine,
while Mintz-Plasse played a nerdy computer
whiz. The show finished the 2016-to-2017 season
as the 38th-most-watched show on network TV. That
may not sound too shabby, but it was apparently
disappointing to CBS, as it was cancelled
after just one season. It certainly didn't
help that critics also hated the series, with
The Hollywood Reporter for one calling it, quote,
"a malaise of millennial minstrelsy."
Being associated with a failed sitcom
given every chance to succeed can't
be a good look for anyone's career.
"Oh, let me help you with this guy here. Oh!"
Around the same time that The Great
Indoors was underwhelming viewers,
Mintz-Plasse appeared in another quickly
forgotten TV series. Flaked was a Netflix
dramedy that premiered in 2017 about addiction
recovery that starred Will Arnett. Once again,
Mintz-Plasse played a socially awkward
techie. The show lasted a mere two seasons,
with Mintz-Plasse showing up in
three episodes of the first season.
Mintz-Plasse isn't just an actor. He's also a
dedicated musician, and his projects on that
front are clearly just as important to him as
being on screen. He's spending a lot of his
time these days practicing, performing, and
recording with his indie rock band, MainMan.
While he's definitely the most famous
member of that group outside of music,
he doesn't have the showiest role in the
band, as he strums away on the bass guitar.
Still, he knows where to find his audience,
as the band debuted their very 70s-style
video for its Steely Dan-esque single "WWH"
on Funny or Die's YouTube channel in 2017.
And MainMan isn't even Mintz-Plasse's only
musical project, as he drummed for a group
called The Young Rapscallions and played bass
for another band called Bear on Fire. Splitting
his time this way is exactly what he wants
to keep doing. In 2015, he told Stereogum,
"I would love to keep balancing the two. I think
I'm very lucky and grateful for where I am right
now, that I can do both. Acting, you can work
for three months and not work for six months.
So in that time, I love the momentum of
music and everything that's going on.
The momentum right now is very musical.
I kinda just go with the flow."
While Mintz-Plasse isn't headlining
big studio comedies these days,
he does frequently show up for a supporting
role or cameo appearance in movies involving
his Superbad castmate Seth Rogen. These gigs
keep Mintz-Plasse in the public eye and allow
him to stay busy making the kind of movies
that made him famous in the first place. They
also keep him around as a solid part of Rogen's
prolific and lucrative filmmaking enterprise.
For example, in 2017's The Disaster Artist, which
Rogen co-produced and had a supporting role in,
Mintz-Plasse has a small, uncredited role.
He had a bigger part in 2013's apocalyptic
comedy This is the End, in which Rogen and his
usual gang of collaborators play heightened,
terrible versions of themselves
who lose their minds as the world
ends. Mintz-Plasse shows up as himself to be
sucked into Hell. Rogen even let Mintz-Plasse
deliver a completely absurd male anatomy joke
in 2014's Neighbors, in which he played Scoonie,
a ridiculously well-endowed young man.
It seems that as long as Mintz-Plasse's
colleagues are still making movies, they'll
often have a part with his name on it.
You may not have seen Mintz-Plasse too
much lately, but there's a good chance
you've heard him. He's been a go-to player
for DreamWorks Animation for a while now,
ever since he landed the role of thoughtful
Viking Fishlegs in 2010's How to Train Your
Dragon. He's gone on to reprise that role in
multiple sequels and TV shows, and he worked
with DreamWorks again on the Trolls franchise
as the voice of the villainous King Gristle.
Mintz-Plasse no longer sports the whiny voice
he utilized with great skill as McLovin.
He's in fact developed into a skilled
and versatile voice-over performer,
playing characters in the likes of such
projects as Marmaduke and ParaNorman.
Becoming an in-demand voice actor isn't a
bad thing by any stretch. It's great work
for an actor with a particular skill set, and
Mintz-Plasse's enthusiastic vocal performances
indicate that he loves doing it. Entire careers
can unfold within the realm of voice acting that
are just as lucrative, creatively challenging,
and memorable as ones rooted in live-action.
But even with all these positive attributes, voice
acting is simply not going to get Mintz-Plasse's
face on the radar of Hollywood casting agents
the same way that live-action parts would.
Five years after Superbad
exploded onto the big screen,
Mintz-Plasse was given an opportunity to break
out of his McLovin image while still remaining
within the fold of big Hollywood comedies.
In 2012, he joined the cast of Get a Job,
which was helmed by Rodger Dodger director
Dylan Kidd. Mintz-Plasse was cast as Ethan,
a housemate of the main character Will, played
by Miles Teller. Will is a recent college
graduate who doesn't quite know what to do with
himself professionally upon being thrust into
adulthood. Ethan winds up being the most
financially, if dubiously, successful
member of Will's social group when he designs
a popular smartphone app that enables stalkers.
"Say there's a person that you wanna find, but
they don't wanna be found, right? Okay? Like
there's this girl, and you've called her a million
times, and she just won't return your messages."
Unfortunately, Get a Job didn't do much to advance
Mintz-Plasse's momentum at a critically important
stage in his career. Distribution issues initially
delayed its release by two years, and ultimately,
it wouldn't be available to the public until
2016. That's a whopping four years after it
was filmed in 2012, a whole bachelor's degree's
worth of time. To add insult to injury, critics
seriously hated the movie, with Dan Mecca of The
Film Stage calling it, quote, "a brutally cynical,
largely unfunny film." It was released straight
to home video in the United States, though it did
play to theatergoers in South Africa, where it
earned a little more than $23,000. Mintz-Plasse
certainly got a job making this movie, but
it didn't really lead to any further ones.
One reason for Mintz-Plasse's low visibility in
Hollywood is that he seems to genuinely prefer
things this way. Between his private nature,
his choice to pursue supporting roles,
his frequent voice acting gigs, and his musical
pursuits, there's little sign that he even wants
to headline blockbusters or take the lead in a
major network sitcom. But if he ever does want
to pursue either of those things, it's definitely
not too late for him to do so. He's got the
acting chops to make it happen, not to mention the
goodwill that comes from co-starring in Superbad,
an enduringly popular millennial touchstone.
A career is never really dead in Hollywood;
it just needs the right jump-start.
And in recent years, Mintz-Plasse has finally
started shedding the nerd roles so commonly
offered to him. In fact, his career has
taken recent turns into more artistic
and idiosyncratic territory. In 2019, he was
hired to play a small but pivotal role as a
creepy guy in 2020’s satirical thriller Promising
Young Woman, which starred Carey Mulligan as a
woman seeking to avenge her best friend by
preying on men who claim to be nice guys.
"I just thought that you were-"
"Drunk?"
"Yeah."
"Really drunk?"
"F---. Yeah."
"Well, I'm not. But that's good, isn't it?"
"I think you should leave."
And Mintz-Plasse has also been getting
weird by voicing "Son" in the grotesquely
puppeteered Comedy Central series Blark
and Son. So in reality, Mintz-Plasse is
still hanging with comedy's cool kids, just
in a slightly different way than he used to.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.